you guys do have deacon philippe joining
this season to come and play with y'all
what was that like to have him on set he
was great
i mean i wish he was with us like
through every single episode he was
awesome professional funny it was his
first acting job so it was pretty cool
we were there for his very first take it
was cool this is his first like acting
credit yeah
the debut of daxton was unreal your
social status has skyrocketed so much
that now people hate you you used to
make that face all the time what was the
vibe like coming back because you know
obviously you had two seasons on your
belt so was it like reuniting for the
summer with your friends yeah i mean it
was just like getting the gang back
together and it was fun the vibes were
good it's like
two seasons under our belt we're in our
flow and it's like we're like becoming
so
into our characters it's just more like
playing by that point
i was so impatient to get started with
season three i was like after we wrapped
season two i was like i don't wanna wait
i just wanna like go right into it right
totally on deck with what they're saying
i think for me personally it was cool
because i've only had one season under
my belt but i think coming in the season
i was a lot more familiar with everyone
there's more of a friendship thing going
on and it was just fun okay so the
friendship group this season is really
focused on losing their virginity i
thought i was ready but maybe i'm not
wait we are smart and idiots are banging
all the time if they can do it we can
learn how to do it too how do you think
that kind of changes their dynamic and
what hijinks ensue for the group because
of it and i feel like they've always
wanted to lose their virginity since
season one a lot happens and a lot of
relationships
a lot of
sex just all of it and ramona knowing
where like the storyline was going for
the group how much fun was it to share
more scenes with the guys and play off
them oh you know i love the guys
it was great honestly ben norris is so
much fun to act with and he's genuinely
so nice he's almost as nice as the girls
so it was a great time i'm kidding he's
awesome okay obviously a through line of
this whole show really but especially
this season again is this love triangle
right between paxton ben and davies did
we discover that being in a relationship
doesn't solve all of our problems please
try dr ryan the entire olivia rodrigo
album would disagree with you no are you
team ben or team paxton who should end
up with davey it changes for me every
season he does the season one i was team
band he's in two team packs in season
three i'm trying to remember i think i'm
still team paxton season three but
halfway through i switch up to team ben
season one i was team davey season two
team paxton season three team ben so i
have no idea whose team i'm on anymore i
mean if you had to pick who do you think
she'll end up with i think
she'll end up happy i'll say that such a
great answer
oh man what a pro
season one i was
team neither so probably team baby he's
in two i was team paxton but like team
packs and towards the end like after he
realized what he lost and like running
after it because you know that's how it
goes season three i'll say team men
anissa doesn't want her anymore he could
take him that's right
you're trying to get rid of them now i
love it i'm waiting for like next season
for them to throw a curve ball like she
graduates and all of a sudden i don't
know like michael b jordan shows up for
her so oh my god
what do you want fans to know about you
know where this show is headed now that
we know that season four is gonna be the
final season four everybody will be
happy
with well obviously
maybe some people won't and some people
will i feel like everybody will be happy
with the ending season okay i think
season four
is just gonna come full circle and
everything will just make sense and i
hope the audience will like feel content
and satisfied about it megan were you
satisfied like knowing what you know
about next season yeah absolutely i
think it's a really beautiful way to
encompass and and kind of close or tie
the bow on all of these characters yeah
i'm really excited to see what audiences
think
[Music]
you